lebron's been in the league what 18 17
years he's never been that guy
when you're going strength against
strength and you're stronger sometimes
you got to put that extra on and as he
put the into it guy got hit in the face
now stuart reacted like he was supposed
to wreck you hit somebody in the face
right yeah you do yeah that way no no no
no somebody hit you in the face you
possibly oh that was no that wasn't an
open house
that was a trouble no no somebody hit
you in the face you either got to hit
him back or act like you want to hit him
back no but wait it's only two options
there's only two options no it wasn't it
got hilarious in this regard
all right
you if he would have acted like that the
first time he like when he got hit i
would have been like yeah it makes sense
but the fan walk with the with the
ladies and then make like you going one
way to run back the other that was
that's
he blacked out that
yeah blacked out
from the university of washington i'm up
from seattle and i know he's big on dish
he respects everybody but if he feels
disrespected that's when things go to
another level i've never seen him like
that
i don't know all right we understand
anger right
right but i'm not talking about the if
it was immediate no but hold on
suspension for him
he didn't react he reacted yeah
absolutely
that's what happened he got hit he was
upset people calmed him down
go ahead reggie go ahead
it was the blood i think that's what
triggered him yeah because and i agree
with jamal this he's a good kid he's a
hard worker he respects the game and
after the hit the initial crack when
lebron went over to him because i do
think lebron went over to him to make
sure he was all right he was fine then
it's once the blood once he tasted the
blood started
he was a vampire i was okay
i was okay with